what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and it's about time for me
to do another attack on titan video
and i thought that a video about the
first and strongest titan would be the
perfect place to start
especially since recently we got
mind-blowing reveals
about the true untold history of the
first titan how she got her titan powers
and more if you enjoy seeing attack on
titan videos on this channel and want to
keep them coming the best thing you
could do is turn that like button blue
and leave suggestions for what topics
you'd like me to cover
next in the comments if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
titan videos and let me know if you
would like to see similar history videos
for each of the nine titan powers
if you're interested in the specific
abilities of the titans
seeing them rank from weakest to
strongest or almost any other attack on
titan topic you can think of you can
find those videos in my attack on time
playlist link in the description now
without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all it
all started with emir fritz
the figure of amir fritz is clouded in
mystery and no story about this
historical figure
was very convincing everyone agreed that
she was the first titan but some
portrayed her as a goddess while other
people portrayed her as a demon who made
a deal with the devil
both versions were clearly biased but
they were the only sources we had to go
off of the true history remained untold
until now around 2000 years ago emir's
village was attacked by the aldean tribe
houses were burned and people's tongues
were cut out the villagers along with
the girl emir
became the slaves of the aldians the
ruler of the aldians was upset one day
when a pig got away
he wanted to know who was responsible
and he was ready to take an eye from
every slave if they didn't want to
cooperate all of the slaves pointed
their fingers at emir emir was then
quote unquote set free only to be hunted
down by
dogs men on horses and arrows crying and
bleeding she came across a giant tree
and entered it she slipped into an
underground body of water
and seemingly came into contact with a
spine-shaped creature
that attached itself to the young girl's
spine at this point the first ever titan
transformation took place
emir became the first to gain the power
of the titans for 13 years
ldn leader fritz used emir's titan
powers to build
roads cultivate the wastelands make
bridges between mountains and so on
in the process the eldian tribe grew
large and wealthy
then fritz decided to reward amir the
girl he tried to kill
by giving her his seed she became his
concubine and acquired his last name
but she remained his slave all the same
he used her titan powers to annihilate
his greatest rival
the nation of marley emir gave birth to
three children maria
rose and sheena fritz after 13 years of
the titan shifter life
emir died during an assassination
attempt when she took a spear in place
of king fritz
emir awoke in a strange land that we've
seen other titan shifters glimpse and
we'll get more into it later
in the meantime king fritz made his
daughters eat emir's dead body in the
physical world
so that the power of the titans would be
passed on and the aldians could continue
to rule the lands
on his deathbed he told his daughters
that the blood of emir
must not die out give birth and multiply
if you die my daughters have my
grandchildren eat your spines
if my grandchildren die their spines
will be passed from child to child end
quote
and so it went emir's original powers
were eventually split into the nighttime
powers we know today the founding titan
attack titan beast titan female titan
jaw titan colossal titan armor titan
carts titan and warhammer titan and the
aldians continued to use these titans to
maintain power until around 17 centuries
later when carl fritz the 145th king
inherited the founding titan he was sick
of conflict including the conflict
between the competing ldn families
and he also felt horrible for the
subjugation that the marlian suffered
under ld
rule and because of all this he chose to
relocate the capital of eldea
to the island where our story starts he
used his titan powers to create three
walls on the island out of countless
colossal titans
he named the three walls after three
daughters of emir fritz
and erased people's memories of the
world beyond the wall
making them think that they were the
last humans in a world overrun by titans
meanwhile the nation of marley still
alive after 1
700 years of subjugation took away all
of lds territory
on the continent and started to
subjugate the remaining aldians
except the tiber family the family that
possessed the warhammer titan who were
viewed as
allies that helped marley bring down the
aldean empire
the 145th king became the first king of
the walls
however in order to protect the fritz
family they were renamed the rhys family
while a fake fritz royal family was set
up
carl also renounced all war letting the
fritz family in marley
and the tiber family know that he would
not retaliate when the nation of marley
decided to destroy the remaining ldns
within the walls
he made it so that his philosophy would
be passed down to all future royal
blooded users of the founding titan
power
and royal-blooded users were supposed to
be the only ones actually capable of
utilizing the founding titan's insane
god-like powers
time passed and the rhys family
continued to pass on the founding titan
from one generation to the next
eventually came to rodris and eures's
father who then passed it down to yuri
reese who in turn passed it down to
rodrice's daughter
and yuri reese's niece frieda reese
things got really crazy though when in
the year 845 the colossal titans showed
up
and kicked through shiganshina's front
gate while annie reiner and bertolt were
infiltrating while maria for marley
aaron's dad grisha yeager confronted the
rhys family including frieda
in their underground crystal hideout
this was a fitting location because it
was where the reese family had passed
down the founding titan for generations
upon generations
grisha was from the outside world and
used to be part of the aldean
restorationist
a group of aldeans on the marlin
continent who were
sick of being treated inhumanely by
their marlene rulers
the aldian spy aaron krueger had given
grisha the attack titan power
and had tasked him with capturing the
founding titan so that he could help the
aldians since the royal
family clearly had no interest in doing
it grisha tried to use words at first
he begged frida to use the founders
power to stop the invading titans and
save the people of the walls from being
eaten grisha is trying to save his
people
and his family but frida is all like we
deserve this
our punishment is at hand she like all
royal blooded founding titans
is brainwashed by carl fritz's
philosophy at this point
and we know carl fritz was sick of
fighting and also felt bad
for what the merlin suffered under ldn
rule so he felt like they needed to
atone for their sins
with their lives pretty ridiculous
especially since the people born within
the walls didn't mistreat any marlenes
at all
but carl fritz wanted to eradicate all
titans and the only way to do that was
to eradicate all of emir's descendants
aka all of his own people probably the
worst king ever but still grisha was
hesitating he thought he couldn't kill
children in order to take the founding
titan power
but here's where things get really crazy
one of the attack titan's special powers
is that it grants one access to future
memories and as a result
future aaron could communicate with his
father at this point
and adult aaron the future user of the
attack titan egged an unwilling grisha
on
until he took the fanning titan and
killed everyone except rodris who
managed to escape
then grisha passed on the power of the
attack titan and the founding titan
to his son aaron and that's about where
the series began
aaron couldn't really use the fading
titan power because he didn't have royal
blood but there were moments when he
came into contact with a royal blooded
titan like dina fritz where he
temporarily gained access to the
founder's powers
the years passed and eventually aaron
convinced his half-brother zeke the user
of the beast titan and a marleian
warrior like reiner
that he wanted the same thing that he
did aaron convinced him that he wanted
to use the founding titan's power
so that the aldians couldn't reproduce
thus all titans would die out
however aaron was just using zeke when
they accessed the mysterious land that
emir fritz entered when she died
they met emir who continued to slave
away following the orders of the royal
blooded aldians
it appeared for a second like aaron's
plan had backfired
zeke had control on this land because he
was the royal blooded one
and it seemed like emir would follow his
wishes ashis followed the wishes of the
royal family for millennia
amir fritz continued to be the
coordinate she had all the power but she
had continued to obey orders all this
time from this world
however aaron does the impossible he
talks to amir and convinces her to lend
him her strength
he tells her that she's not a slave or a
god just a person while hugging her
he tells her that she doesn't need to
serve anyone she can choose what she
does
then aaron suggests that it was amir who
led aaron to this point in the first
place
she wanted someone to free her and that
brings us back to the first ever attack
a titan chapter title
which was to you 2000 years from now
that title appears to have referred to
emir reaching out to aaron
who could finally set her free from her
millennia-long
servitude to the royal fritz family by
winning over
emir aaron gains the ability to use the
founding titan powers as he wishes and
that brings us to the present
aaron has said that he'll put an end to
this world and he's commanding the
countless colossal titans
that were in the walls and using them to
protect the people of the island who
bore him and raised him
because the world outside the walls
wants the extinction of the people
within the walls
and they won't stop until they have
killed every subject of emir
aaron has chosen to eliminate them from
this world instead
using the titans of the walls that
catches us up with what's happening
currently
whether aaron is still keeping secrets
from us and from everyone else is yet to
be seen but for now it appears that he's
rejected the world's desire to eliminate
his people
and has decided to end the cycle of
hatred by completely wiping
out the other side for him at this point
it seems like that's the only path to
freedom
what he plans to do with himself and the
titan power is once he's carried out his
mission
only time will tell and that is it for
today's video about the untold history
of the first and strongest titan
ever who was sometimes revered as a
goddess that came into contact with the
source of all organic matter and
sometimes like a demon who made a deal
with the devil
however the untold truth that people had
no idea about was
that she was just a human as aaron said
who came into contact with a mysterious
spine-like creature
that attached itself to her while she
was running for her life
it seems that like aaron what amir
always seeked
was freedom from having to obey the
royal fritz family
and that will to be free somehow
manifested in erin making contact with
her 2000 years later
and freeing her or perhaps more
accurately helping her realize that she
was free the whole time
and didn't have to obey the royal family
i think that so far
attack on titan has been one of the
greatest stories of all time
and emir's own complicated and
mind-blowing story
definitely encapsulates some of that
greatness if you did enjoy this video
and want to see more
attack on time videos like it then the
best thing you could do is smash that
like button until it's blue if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial hit that notification bell
and select all or you will miss future
attack on time videos
leave suggestions for what videos you
would like to see next
in the comments and while you wait for
the next video feel free to check out my
colossal playlist of attack on time
videos where you'll find videos
ranking the titans from weakest to
strongest videos explaining the ackerman
videos going into depth with particular
characters and
much much more a very special thank you
goes to our patrons over on patreon who
help make videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord tuigo himself
alpha sigma and are the one to your
patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans stephen and grotta alolan
authento world
steelers acquire respect pate hepa
jonathan king brandon of isles papa
smurf
emperor otaku thomas jones ken mano
and admirath and our pro hero to your
patrons the one and only gilgamesh who's
the current most donated overall
champion
of the world nothing but a fan jason
wilson kings elders anatoly kazatsky
angel cruz
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci alicia
actor
jessica kayla font hinokami and water
bonnie parks rethu and de aura
deadly saint and stern hawkins thank you
all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to
anime patreon.com and becoming a patron
today for as well as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these epic people right here and you'll
even get access to our private patron
only discord
where we talk about anime life and of
course thank memes so check out
patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button
next to the subscribe button that you've
hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever
way you choose to support us you can get
the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you